the time has come to take your oral exam
and the first question is a doozy
what's the difference in a turn
coordinator and a turn and slip
indicator
if you don't know the answer that's okay
we're going to talk about that today and
we're also going to talk about how both
of them work
if you take a round object like this and
you spin it quickly around an axis the
circular object becomes resistant to
outside forces
for instance when you spin a toy top
like this it's resistant to those side
forces that would make it fall over and
we call this rigidity in space and this
is one of the principles of a gyroscope
and when we look at both of these
instruments both of these are gyroscopic
instruments and your airplane could have
either one of these so we're going to
talk about both of them today and we'll
start by talking about the turn and slip
indicator i want to draw your attention
to the words dc electric down here at
the bottom this is important to know
because on most training aircraft the
vacuum system doesn't spin the gyros on
the turn and slip indicator like it does
on the attitude indicator and the
heading indicator so that tells me that
if i lose battery power or one of these
wires gets cut or ripped this thing's
not going to work the way it should and
now let's take a look at the turn
coordinator guess what this one's also
dc electric
and when you turn on the master switch
in your airplane typically you'll hear
the gyro start spinning in both of these
instruments and if you don't hear that
sound these things aren't going to work
correctly and if either one of these
instruments lose electrical power you'll
see a red off flag pop up like this one
and that lets us know that this thing is
not working correctly which brings me to
my next question can i go fly under
visual flight rules without this guy and
this is a legitimate oral check ride
question that i've heard asked to
students and don't let the way they ask
you this throw you off just remember
your a tomato flames acronym this is the
vfr day minimum equipment requirements
found in far 91 205 and now that that's
out of the way let's get back to talking
about how the turn and slip indicator
works
now while the turn and slip indicator
doesn't tell you any kind of banking
information what it does tell you is if
you're in a left or right turn and if
you'll notice here at the bottom it can
also give you information so you can
make a two minute turn what exactly does
that mean let's say for example the
needle of your turn and slip indicator
is pointed over here to this left tick
mark if you can keep the needle on this
tick mark the whole time it's going to
take you two minutes to turn 360 degrees
this equates to about three degrees per
second and this is what we call the
standard rate turn you're going to be
using this a lot more when you go for
your instrument rating but for now it's
something important that you should at
least be aware of the turn and slip
indicator operates on a principle known
as gyroscopic procession this principle
basically states that anytime i apply a
force to a spinning gyroscope like this
there's a resultant force that occurs 90
degrees ahead of the force applied along
the plane of rotation in other words if
i poke the spinning gyro right here the
part that's going to want to move is 90
degrees in front of that location not
only is a gyro rotor able to spin on its
axis but a single gimbal allows the gyro
rotor to tilt one direction or another
now let's say our airplane makes a right
hand turn
when that happens it brings the gyro
rotor with the aircraft and this causes
a force to be placed on the side of the
gyro rotor and because of procession
this force is then transferred to 90
degrees ahead of that spot when this
happens the gyro rotor tilts in that
direction and because the gyro rotor is
tied to the indicator needle this gives
us an indication how our turn is
progressing and when the airplane stops
turning spring tension returns the gyro
rotor to its upright position and the
needle moves back to the center and
that's how this device works to give us
our rate of turn in the airplane this
allows us to tell if we're turning three
degrees per second greater than three
degrees per second less than three
degrees per second or maybe we're in a
bank but we're not turning like we
thought we were the turn coordinator
works very similar to the turn and slip
indicator
the big difference is that on the turn
coordinator the gimbal that holds the
gyro in is tilted at a 30 degree angle
this allows the turn coordinator to be
sensitive to the banking motions of the
airplane and this in turn gives us
initial bank indications and as the
aircraft banks to the right so does the
miniature aircraft on the turn
coordinator and just like the turn and
slip indicator this instrument also lets
us know when our aircraft is turning at
3 degrees per second but it does not
tell you your bank angle and this is a
common misconception so what this
instrument gives you is an indication
that your aircraft is in a roll or in a
bank initially
then it gives you an indication at what
your turn rate is so now when your
instructor asks you what the turn
coordinator is for you can tell them it
gives you roll rate and your rate of
turn
now on both of these instruments i'm
sure you already noticed that they have
a ball inside of a glass tube at the
bottom this is called an inclinometer
some pilots call it the slip skid
indicator but before i explain how this
thing works i want to show you some of
my favorite gear when it comes to flying
fly boys and pivot make some of the best
flight bags ipad holders and knee boards
that there are available i've been using
their stuff for years and i've never
been disappointed in fact i've been
using the same knee board for about 10
years i still use it and it still works
great and is in great shape be sure to
check out their website in the
description below after you watch this
video now let's get back to talking
about the inclinometer
and as i said before this is nothing
more than a little ball inside of a
curved glass tube and the ball is free
to move around as forces act on the
airplane when the aircraft is in
straight and level flight gravity pulls
the ball to the lowest point in the
curved tube and when you make a turn as
long as the load is perpendicular with
the wings the ball remains centered but
this doesn't always happen
sometimes a sideways force acts upon the
airplane and this displaces the ball to
the left or to the right
when you make a turn as long as the nose
of the airplane is aligned with your
direction of travel the ball will remain
centered
this is what we call a coordinated turn
but let's say we're making a turn and
the tail of the aircraft is skidding to
the outside of the turn the ball will
then be displaced to the outside
this is what we call a skidding turn
to fix this problem we'll use the rudder
pedals to align the nose of the airplane
with the direction of the turn
another thing that could happen is that
the tail of your airplane slips to the
inside of the turn when this happens the
ball inside of your inclinometer also
slips to the inside of the turn
something that really helped me
understand how this instrument works is
that the ball is a picture of where the
tail of your airplane is
and to get the tail back in line with
the direction of travel step on the ball
to move the tail back into position but
just be aware if you step on the ball
too much you can actually use too much
rudder and get yourself back into a
skidding turn
and in this case you don't necessarily
need to step on the ball just release
some of that right rudder pressure
and this is how we use the rudder pedals
and the inclinometer to maintain
coordinated flight
so what's the difference in the turn
coordinator and the turn and slip
indicator
well both of them indicate our rate of
turn and they both provide slip and skid
indications but the turn coordinator
also gives us banking indications and a
visual picture of a roll raid but
remember it does not indicate your bank
angle i hope you enjoyed today's video
click that like button if you did and
please consider subscribing and i'll see
you in this video right here or maybe
this playlist see ya